هذا وتظاهر اليوم في تل ابيب وحيث الاف
الاسرائيليين للمطالبه باقاله رئيس
الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو وحكومته واجراء
انتخابات مبكره وجاءت الدعوه للتظاهر هذه
الليله تحت عنوان ان الاسرائيليين يستحقون
قياده افضل لا سما لاخفائها في منع هجوم
السابع من اكتوبر والتهجم من قبل وزراء في
الحكومه على رئيس اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي
هارتي هاليفي خلال جلسه المجلس الوزاري
المصغر يوم الخميس الماضي وقد نظم هذه
المظاهرات التي خرجت في مدن اسرائيليه
اخرى نشطا وممثلون عن الاحتجاجات السابقه
قبل اندلاع الحرب على غزه والتي طالبت
بوقف التشريعات القضائيه الى جانب عائلات
جنود قتلوا خلال الحرب وسكان من مستوطنات
غلاف
غزه تنضم الينا الان من تلبيب مراسله
الجزيره نجوان سمري اهلا بك نجوان نقف معك
على بطبيعه الحال هذه التظاهرات تتزامن
مع هذا الفيديو الذي تم نشره لعدد من
الاسرى الذين قتلوا بيد جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي لم يتمكن الجيش من تحريرهم كما
يعترف من خلال التحقيقات بانه اخطا في
قواعد الاشتباك ضعي في اجواء هذه
التظاهرات
والمطالبات نعم بالفعل هذه التظاهرات بدات
تزداد اكثر فاكثر عبد السلام سواء كان
للمطالبه بال العمل الفوري من اجل الافراج
عن كافه الاسرى المحتجزين في غزه وابرام
صفقه تبادل حتى لو كانت مقابل الافراج عن
كافه الاسرى الفلسطينيين في سجون الاحتلال
لكنها ربما ام امتزجت هذا المساء مع
مظاهره اخرى خرجت للمطالبه ايضا بطاحه
رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو ب
وبحكومة تل ابيب و وهي ايضا تنادي
بالاطاحة لهم ولكن ايضا عائلات لقتلى من
ال الجنود الذين قتلوا خلال المعارك في
غزه
وايضا من منظمي الاحتجاجات التي سبقت هذه
الحرب كانوا قد جمدوا هذه الاحتجاجات مع
بدايه هذه الحرب التي تتعلق بالتغييرات
القضائيه التي ارادت وسعت حكومه نتنياهو
الى سنها وتشريعها في الكنيست الاسرائيلي
لكن هذه الاحتجاجات توقفت مع بدايه هذه
الحرب والان عادوا على الاقل جزء من
المنظمين اكدوا بعوده هذه الاحتجاجات
للمطالبه بال الاطاحه
وعزل بنيامين نتنياهو عن منصبه الالاف
يشاركون في هذه المظاهرات في تل ابيب ولكن
ايضا في مدن اخرى شهدت هذه الليله مظاهرات
مماثله في مدينه قيساريا وفي مدينه حيفا
وهذا ربما يؤشر على حراك جديد سيبدا اي
مجددا ضمن هذه ال الاحتجاجات
للمطالبه بتغيير القياده السياسيه واجراء
انتخابات مبكره هذا امر غير مسبوق وامر
استثنائي يعتبر في اسرائيل ان يتم
المطالبه في اي بدء هذه الحسابات خلال
الحرب لطالما كانت هناك انتخابات في
اسرائيل مباشره بعد الحروب وبعد المعارك
العسكريه ل سيما تلك التي كانت تحقق
اخفاقات وعدم انتصار وفقا لما حدد لها لكن
الان ان ان تبدا هذه الاصوات بالتعالي
خلال هذا الحرب خلال فتره حرب فهذا يشير
الى ان الازمه عميقه جدا وان هناك حسابات
بدات بدا الشارع الاسرائيلي يطالب بها ولم
ينتظر حتى انتهاء هذه الحرب سمعنا قبل
قليل بنيامين نتنياهو يصدر مقطع فيديو
مباشره بعد انتهاء عطله السبت نشر هذا
الفيديو وذكر بدايه باحداث السابع من
اكتوبر ولماذا بدات هذه الحرب ودعى الى
وضع كل الخلافات جانبا والالتفاف حول
اهداف هذه الحرب ومواصله هذه الحرب من اجل
تحقيق الاهداف وهذا الفيديو قد يشير الى
امرين الاول ان نتنياهو من جهه يريد تبرئه
ايضا نفسه من كل الاتهامات الموجهه له
خلال ال 48 ساعه الاخيره من انه قاد وساهم
وبادر الى هذا الهجوم والتهجم على رئيس
اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي ولكنه ايضا يريد
ان يظهر بمظهر الشخص الذي يحاول توحيد
الصفوف الا الصف الاسرائيلي وتوحيد الشارع
الاسرائيلي لكن الاهم انه يبدو بان هناك
محاوله لاحتواء هذه الخلافات
وح نعم
بدات تنعكس ايضا على الشارع الاسرائيلي
وليس فقط نعم سنتناول هذه مع ضيفنا بعد
قليل شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه الايضاحات
سنتناولها بطبيعه الحال بتفصيل اكثر نجوان
سمري من تل ابيب شكرا لك